So now let's talk about how
password-based authentication
can be implemented.
So we know the evidence that's
going to be provided is
a password user is going to supply,
and then they're going to type or
touch the screen or something like that.
And that's going to follow,
you're telling the system who they are,
which typically they
provide the user ID.
So they tied their user ID and
password, let's say.
And the system now has this task of,
well, how do I know that this is
the correct password for this user, and
if it is the correct password,
authentication will be successful.
So how can we perform this check?
So you would say well an obvious
solution to this problem is that
we ask users to share their
passwords with the system.
So the first time this is called
registration or enrollment or
some out of band method by which.
Of course the system has to know
something about your secret.
If it doesn't, it can't check it.
So let's say the secret is password so
we have a set of users with passwords.
And the system stores those passwords.
It's trusted system we,
let's say, give it our password.
And if we do that, it's not a good idea
and actually we won't have to do that.
But if you do that than how can we do
that check that we're talking about.
I will see it's pretty straight forward.
All we have to do is impair the type
password with the one that's stored.
So where do we store it?
We have to store it in a file.
People come back, you turn the computer
off and then come back and
login so
this information has to persist.
Your computer multiple sessions, so
persistent information
is stored in files.
One thing we should be smart enough to
do is that only the trusted root or
admin be able to read this file.
The login program is going to run on
behalf of them and they are the ones
that are going to check and somebody's
trying to authenticate themselves.
So this file should be made readable
only by the admin or the root.
The most user we have in the system.
But what if we make a mistake?
What if permissions are set incorrectly?
The permissions are set incorrectly
somebody else may be able to
read that file.
And if they're able to read that file,
they're able to learn everyone's
password, which is not a good thing.
Even if the permissioners are set right,
why should an admin be able
to know all the passwords?
Okay, every user's password,
if they know it, there's no reason for
them to have access to passwords
of all users in the system.
And the one reason we don't
want to have that is that in
case you have security breach,
the passwords are going to be exposed,
everyone's password is going
to be exposed to that hacker.
So it's clear that something about the
secret has to be shared with the system,
the password has to be
shared with the system.
But storing those secrets in a file,
even if you do access control,
is not a good idea.
So can we do better?
So indeed,
we can actually do better, and
the way to think about that is that we
don't store the passwords themselves,
but store something that
is derived from it.
It's not the actual password But
something that is possible to
get hold of only if you had access
to the password at some point.
Or at least in the beginning or
the enrollment time or
when the password was changed and then
you're not storing the full password but
just something derived from it.
The question is if you're storing
something derived from what is it and
how do you use it.
The result that we
derived from password.
One way to do that is to use what
is called a one-way function.
This called are called hash functions.
Hash functions are widely used to
take an arbitrary length of input and
produce a fixed size output that
is fairly unique to the input.
And one-way basically says that it's
easy to compute given the input of
the hash value is easy to compute, but
it's very hard to compute the input
if you just had the hash value.
So such functions exist, we're going to
talk about some examples of those.
So thing to remember here is that
given a password it produced
a hash value of that password.
And going from password to hash value
is straightforward going in the other
direction which is from hash value
to the password is really hard.
So what you're going to do is you're
going to use a function like that so
rather than storing the password we're
going to store something derived
from it.
In particular, we're going to store
a hash value, and that's what we're
going to have, and even the hash values
that we have, those have to be stored in
a file as earlier we were talking
we're storing the passwords in a file.
Even this file should be readable only
for the perlist user or the admin user
that we're talking about on whose behalf
the log in program is going to run.